hi have you ever wondered how to get
started in a career in the cloud I'm
suhita a strategic Cloud engineer at
Google Cloud Professional Services
I'm here to walk you through what a data
engineering career could look like at
Google Cloud
it's common to confuse data engineering
with data science so let me clear that
out for you data scientists strangle
data using statistics and machine
learning skills to bring out deeper
insights for businesses to leverage data
Engineers design and Implement how that
data reaches them by developing scalable
data pipelines and defining user access
security networking parameters and
building secure data management
ecosystems both skills to complement one
another well and are gradually
integrating into scalable services
offered on Google Cloud Google Cloud
Professional Services or Cloud PSO
partners with our customers to solve
their biggest challenges with the best
of Google Cloud we support our customers
with designing and implementing
efficient effective Enterprise data
ecosystems we help Enterprises
efficiently Leverage The Best of cloud
for their information management needs
in a matter of best tailored to their
industry needs and digital
transformation vision
Professional Services has multiple
specializations under it covering
networking security infrastructure data
and analytics and machine learning data
analytics has additional specializations
to align with customer goals along data
Lake modernization business intelligence
streaming analytics and databases to
name a few
ESO engagements involve one or more of
three
three experience for our customers a
strategic Cloud engineer or ski designs
large-scale data processing systems
develops data pipelines optimized for
scaling and troubleshoots potential
technology problems we provide
application guidance to ingest store and
analyze data in a scalable and efficient
manner Cloud Consultants balance the
hacks of technical design with project
management Cloud Consultants provide
management advisory and Technical
horsepower to customer engagements while
working with client Executives and key
stakeholders to deploy Solutions on
Google Cloud deliver consulting services
and best practice expertise
Cloud program managers or cpms
coordinate priorities and drive customer
success across multiple use cases these
roles are focused on relationship
management project management and
delivery and coordination efforts across
different projects for customers
Cloud Consultants balance the hats of
technical design with project management
Cloud Consultants provide management
advisory and Technical horsepower to
customer engagements while working with
client Executives and key stakeholders
to deploy Solutions on Google Cloud
deliver consulting services and best
practice expertise
Cloud program managers or cpms
coordinate priorities and drive customer
success across multiple use cases these
roles are focused on relationship
management project management and
delivery and coordination efforts across
different projects for customers
in terms of technical preparation the
following concepts are necessary for
Success at interviewing for these
positions Hadoop and big data processing
Frameworks Cloud Computing Services data
warehousing and data processing think
Kafka Flume pops up and related services
for infrastructure and security
additionally programming skills in Java
Python and SQL and overall distributed
system design efforts are tested for
technical roles like strategic Cloud
engineers and Cloud Consultants
besides the technical skills the role is
challenging for emotional intelligence
and external stakeholder influence and
relationship management